it is seven o'clock good to have you
with us this morning a shock resignation
from the prime minister's ethics adviser
has once again put boris johnson's
conduct back in the spotlight lord gyt
had previously admitted frustration over
partygate and refused to deny to mps
that he had considered resigning over
the pm's response for being fined for
breaching lockdown he is the second
person to quit the role
in less than three years so where
exactly does that leave the government
just a week before the public get a
chance to give their verdict in two key
by-elections plenty to get into with the
deputy prime minister dominic wrap in
just a few minutes time it is thursday
16th of june
the prime minister's ethics advisor
resigns
after considering that boris johnson may
have broken the ministerial code
lord guide the second person to quit the
downing street role
in less than three years
police in brazil say a man has confessed
to killing the british journalist dom
phillips and his guide bruno pereira and
has shown them to where the bodies are
buried
[Music]
three specialist courts are being set up
in england as part of a pilot scheme
designed to improve rate convictions
the bank of england is expected to hide
interest rates for a fifth time in a row
pushing up payments from millions of
households across the country
taking the night train to kiev the
leaders of germany france and italy
heading to ukraine's capital in a show
of support
nothing but a pr stunt the captain of a
38 million pound super yacht sanctioned
by the uk government says they've got
the wrong guy
also ahead this morning
tackling the big issues of life and
death i'm going to be joined by the
winner of the women's prize for fiction
ruth ozeki to discuss her novel the book
of form and emptiness
[Music]
and have you ever noticed your older
phones not performing quite as well i'll
be speaking to a tech expert about the
750 million pound claim launched against
apple for allegedly slowing down its
older devices
[Music]
morning all boris johnson's ethics
adviser has resigned after raising
concerns that the prime minister may
well have broken the ministerial code
over partygate lord going has not given
the reasons behind his decision to stand
down but earlier this week he had
refused to deny to mps that he'd
consider quitting over the pm's response
to being found for breaking covert rules
the government says the resignation
comes as a surprise but as our deputy
political editor sam coach reports it's
not the first time over recent years
that this position has been left vacant
a second ethics advisor walks out on
boris johnson after what he himself
labelled an exceptionally busy year did
the prime minister pregnancy occur i
think prime minister's views are clear
in the letter that he sent me on the on
the 31st but do do have a look at that
okay thank you very much in a one
sentence resignation statement lord guyt
gave no reason for quitting in an
appearance before mps on tuesday there
were a few hints
on accusations that he was too close to
number 10
how can i defeat the impression that
you're
suggesting of a sort of uh
uh
of a sort of cozy insufficiently
independent uh relationship i think it's
very hard
and on whether he'd ever considered
resigning
this response there are a few
instruments available to an independent
advisor and
important to
consider what is going to work best
again i haven't
i haven't given you a direct answer in
14 months in the job clashes resulted in
multiple threats to resign it seems
tuesday's committee appearance was the
final straw
the ethics advisor who resigned had been
the principal private secretary to the
queen
the challenge for boris johnson now is
whether he can find another ethics
adviser of anything like the same
standing and what impact will this whole
row have on tory mp's confidence in them
critics quick to point to the bigger
pattern
i think he wanted to achieve change he
wanted to improve the ethical standards
in downing street and he thought he'd be
able to do that um but he was repeatedly
lied to by the prime minister personally
and by the prime minister's team
lots of good people go to work at danny
street and then
they get consumed in the bonfire of
boris johnson's narcissism and
and their reputations are the ones that
are tarnished and ruined number 10
insist lord gait's resignation is a
total surprise having indicated earlier
this week he was happy to continue in
the job for months to come now his
departure yet another headache for a
prime minister trying to perform a
relaunch sam coates sky news westminster
a little surprise then a very busy show
ahead in just a few minutes time i'm
going to be speaking to the deputy prime
minister dominic wrap lots to discuss
following the shock resignation of the
pm's ethics advisor
[Music]
as ukraine pleads for more weapons to
help it fight off russian advances i'm
going to be joined by the former
commander of the joint forces command
general richard barrons
and just after eight o'clock i'll be
joined by labour's shadow international
trade secretary nick thomas simmons as
they announce a plan to make britain
more attractive to new businesses
now police in brazil searching for the
missing british journalist dom phillips
and his colleague bruno pereira say that
a suspect has confessed to their
killings and led them to where the two
were buried their bodies have yet to be
formally identified but will be sent for
a rent forensic analysis skies satya
chowdhury reports
one of the two suspects in the
disappearance of a british journalist
hooded and masked police say he
confessed to killing dom phillips and
his guide bruno pereira and that he led
them to a site where human remains were
being dug up
from now on we move on to a new stage
the phase of identifying these human
remains which are being collected with
the greatest dignity
in order to preserve the chain of
custody and evidence which is very
important
the missing pair had been on a four-day
reporting trip in a remote part of the
amazon
for a book mr phillips was writing
they were last seen 11 days ago
i think the idea of the book was
actually to show the world what uh all
sides
of the amazon conflict or the amazon uh
reality consisted on he wanted to give
this this this human vision but
unfortunately that happened and this
story is never going to be told
two brothers anarildo and ozane de costa
who are local fishermen have been
arrested in what police say is a murder
investigation
anarildo is the main suspect in the case
and police say he told them he used a
firearm to fatally shoot his victims
his brother ozone denies any wrongdoing
and had previously claimed anarildo
confessed under torture
for days local indigenous people have
led the search at one point uncovering
items belonging to the pair
their friends and family had called on
authorities to do more to uncover what
happened
police are yet to confirm the identity
of the remains they found
and until then this community's wait for
answers continues sadia chowdhury sky
news
three dedicated rape courts are being
set up as part of a pilot scheme
designed to improve convictions for
serious sexual offences this guy's laura
bunduck is here with the detail morning
laura and look clearly this is an
announcement of significance and you
give us the details but but as alluded
to part of the reason that this is
significant are those historically low
rates of conviction yeah it's pretty
dismal if you look at it so what's
happening is we've got this trial this
pilot will involve leeds newcastle and
snaresbrook crown court all chosen
because they have above average numbers
of rape and sexual offence cases passing
through them and they will all have a
dedicated courtroom specifically for
these cases now that'll be equipped with
this special video technology which
means that victims
can give a pre-recorded evidence
statement rather than having to go
through the trauma of a live trial
rather than having to come face to face
with their attacker and this is seen as
a significant reason why so few of these
cases end up in in court the government
says it'll use the findings in this
trial to help increase the speed and the
volume of cases passing through the
criminal justice system but as we know
as we've been seeing and hearing about
the figures they are dismally low at the
moment just one figure from the
government uh this year shows that the
average weight a victim who who has a
rape case um has to weigh is 706 days
from the date the rape is reported to
police to the day more than two well
yeah two
best part two years
a huge a here and that's the average so
there'll be some courts where it's a lot
longer than this and that's why
obviously campaigners for victims say
many have simply lost faith in the
system and why change simply can't come
soon enough
laura for now thanks very much indeed
uh we've got a few other stories from
the day now uh starting with the bank of
england uh it is of course expected to
announce a fifth consecutive hound in
interest rates when it convenes later
today in an effort to combat
rising inflation most experts are
predicting a small rise
after data this week showed a further
contraction in the economy yesterday the
u.s federal reserve announced its
biggest rate rise in nearly three
decades
the government will today unveil
measures to prevent landlords in england
banning pets and unreasonably raising
rents as part of a review of the private
rental sector the measures also include
a ban on no fault evictions which allow
landlords to remove tenants without
having to give a reason and it will be
illegal to reject tenants because they
have families or our own benefits
commuters have been advised not to
travel by train unless necessary next
week after rail bosses confirm that
strikes will close half of britain's
railway lines
unions say the action is necessary with
up to more than two thousand frontline
jobs at risk
grocery analysts predict that food
prices will head up quickly this summer
the institute of grocery distribution
says that prices will increase by 15
forcing households to pay more for
staples such as bread milk fruit and
vegetables
apple is facing a legal claim worth over
750 million pounds for allegedly causing
batteries on older iphone models to slow
down the consumer champion jonathan
goodman is seeking damages for over 25
million british customers claiming that
apple encouraged customers to download a
software update that reduced the
performance of older handsets
now nato defense ministers are meeting
in brussels this morning as ukraine
again issues an urgent plea for more
weapons to help it fight off russian
advances it comes as a kremlin spokesman
has warned that relations with the
united states are at a very hot point of
confrontation uh let's bring in our
security and defense editor deborah
haynes is in brussels for us this
morning good to see you deborah and good
to see you outside of ukraine what are
we going to be seeing happen today what
is it that ukrainians want and what is
it that the defense ministers can
provide
well as you said ukraine has been
speaking repeatedly in increasingly
urgent
tones sorry um for the need for more
heavy weapons and yesterday ministers
meeting here at nato headquarters met
with ukraine's defense minister there
was what's called the ukraine contact
group with this which is a new grouping
of of countries there's actually around
50 countries now contributing to this
group giving weapons um ammunition and
making other pledges to help ukraine
but clearly ukraine doesn't believe it's
going far enough but the the us the uk
and others were stressing very strongly
that they are doing all they can pushing
every single lever they have available
to ensure that they give ukraine what it
needs but there's clearly a gap there
and today ministers defense ministers
from the nato alliance are meeting again
and on the agenda is all about nato
itself and improving further the
defenses of this alliance from what they
see as an increasingly aggressive and
dangerous russia and also dealing with
other challenges such as the one posed
by china and this work is taking place
ahead of a key summit at the end of this
month where leaders of the nato alliance
will be meeting in madrid and the
expectation the hope is that that will
be the moment that nato really sets out
exactly how it's changing its posture
its defense its deterrence posture in
the face of what has been a fundamental
reshaping of european security and of
course right at the top of that as well
is how best to help ukraine to do more
to defend uh to enable ukraine to defend
itself and then there finally there is
that question about the expansion of
nato you'll remember that finland and
sweden two countries historically
neutral have decided that they want to
join nato uh in the wake of russia's
invasion of ukraine nato members
welcoming this apart from one turkey
there's there's questions over whether
or not turkey will back down on its
concerns about allowing those two
nations to join nato the uk is going to
be playing a key role in that with the
uk's defense secretary revealing that he
plans to travel to turkey to try to help
resolve turkey's concerns about this
expansion um it's related to
their concerns about kurdish terrorism
in fact um and the uk defense secretary
believing that it will be resolved by
madrid others are not so optimistic
fascinating meeting ahead deborah for
now thank you very much indeed
now sky news has been told that the
owner of a russian-owned 38 million
pound yacht that was seized by the
government is not on the sanctions list
at the time ministers did not reveal the
name of the super yacht's owner but
described its ownership as deliberately
well hidden skies arthur bennett reports
it's become a symbol of the crackdown on
russian money the first super yacht to
be detained in uk waters the fee has now
sat in london's canary wharf for more
than two months
good afternoon welcome to fate but the
ship's captain says it's being held
unfairly the victim of a government pr
stunt
at the time we were detained we were the
only boat here
it was easy pickings
easy pickings done for uh social media
it's
headline grabbing click bait attention
seeking
what you see here is actually the floor
of the pool one press of a button and
that goes down as well as the
disappearing pool it has a cinema and
so-called infinity wine cellar 400
bottles deep 40 million pounds worth of
luxury the captain insists has been
bought with clean money we've got some
rotating pieces of furniture we're told
the owner is a russian businessman who
made his wealth in civil engineering
none of that information links the owner
of the boat
to any position in in russian politics
to to mr putin or any other political
aspiration
and you believe that i do i've known him
for 11 years
the detention order names the owner as
sergey naomenko he's not on any
sanctions list but legally speaking that
doesn't matter a connection to russia is
enough for the yacht to be held
but the government claims there's more
to it posing for photos back in march
the transport secretary said the yacht
belonged to a putin crony who's hiding
behind a complex paper trail the boats
registered to accompany instant kits and
nevis and carries the maltese flag
it's a perfectly normal structure and
within that structure mr naumenko is
referred to as the ultimate beneficial
owner so that is all perfectly open so
there's no nefarious background to this
it is
in my world borg standard practice
at 58 meters long this is actually
considered small by super yacht
standards some are over a hundred meters
in length but when it comes to applying
sanctions against russia the government
clearly sees this as a prize catch the
department for transport said we stand
firmly by our decision to detain assets
such as the fee which satisfy both the
scope and purpose of sanctions the
secretary of state will continue to act
within his available powers to ratchet
up the economic pressure on russia
as the yacht's detained and not seized
the owner is liable for the ten thousand
pounds a month mooring fees a drop in
the ocean for him perhaps but one he
doesn't think he should pay iva bennett
sky news
uh as you can see uh joining us now on
the sofa the justice secretary the
deputy prime minister dominic rabb
lovely to see you this morning
and we do have a significant
announcement on that we will get to and
i promise you we'll spend some time on
that but i do i i do need to start with
the resignation of lord guy
hand on heart
do you believe that this government
always 100 of the time operates
ethically
yes i do i think we're doing our best
for the country i think you've seen that
through the pandemic with a vaccine roll
out
i think you've seen it with getting the
economy back up and running i think
you've seen the moral leadership the
prime minister has shown on ukraine do
we make mistakes look it happens we're
human we're fallible but actually in
relation to partygate which is what
you're alluding to prime minister held
up his hand he's apologized he's
overhauled number 10. i do think also
people expect us to get on with that
crucial job particularly with the cost
of living challenge affecting so many
people i can i completely agree people
definitely want you to get on with the
job but i do need to ask why has a
second ethics advisor resigned from this
government what are lord guides stated
reasons for doing this well the stated
reasons of course he set out uh
overnight but were very limited so
he just said he thought it was the right
time to step down look let me tell you
what i know um first of all he had been
engaged with the prime minister and
number 10 this week
and discussing staying on for six months
so
i think man standing he was committed to
the role
i think he had a pretty rough grilling
by mps this week i think sometimes we in
the media as politicians
uh maybe underestimate how civil
servants feel with that kind of scrutiny
um and thirdly there was a particular
issue
commercially sensitive matter in the
national interest which was asked to
look at i don't know which aspect of
this i suspect there will be in fact i
know there will be an update from number
10 later which will be great but that
will be their response to his letter why
have we not seen lord gout's resignation
letter that's pretty unprecedented for
circumstances such as this well he's
given a statement um and i can't tell
you i'm not a psychologist it's not a
statement it's a sentence he has written
info to the prime minister as people do
generally when they're hired by this
government and they choose to resign
they set out their reasons at least for
departure he has done so to the prime
minister i didn't i so i did i don't
know that whether there's a full letter
or whether a full letter and reply will
come out there'll be an update from
number 10 later today i genuinely now as
always try and do when we i'm telling
you what i know
when will he be replaced because with
respect it does rather feel that getting
another ethics adviser might be a
priority for this government and look i
think the role is important we'll do it
as soon as possible i think number 10
have made that clear
and you don't perhaps detect any
problems in hiring a third ethics
advisor in in as many years i mean you
you hired a new cost of living czar the
other day david buttress who said that
boris has got to go he just has to you
can't survive judgment like this when
you're at the point of having to hire
people who have explicitly stated that
boris johnson should resign all is not
well in government well i'm going to put
it the other way i think the fact that
he is notwithstanding previous tweets he
may have made
willing to serve under this government
under the leadership of the prime
minister is a positive i think it says a
number of things i'm not sure quite sure
that people will agree with you that
it's a positive i think it says
something about mr buttress but it's not
just of course
lord guide that resigned uh this week
last week you had the anti-corruptions
are resigned john penrose
well look john's a an mp i think he was
clear on his christians the prime
minister i've worked with him on things
like the magnitsky sanctions i'm afraid
i just disagree i mean we know that
there are conservative mps who have been
critical of the prime minister but he
had 59 support
and we're getting on with the job as i
as i mentioned okay you mentioned
two in five of your parliamentary
colleagues in the best case scenario
basically all of the back benches feel
that the prime minister does not have
the ability to lead neither the party
either the party or the country the
anti-corruptions are goes last week
making his complaints very public we
have lord gait two days ago saying that
the prime it would be reasonable to say
that the prime minister had broken the
ministerial code and then he resigns the
following day you take all of that
together and it is your position that
this does not reflect badly on the prime
minister look i think we've had a
difficult patch but we're getting on
with the job you haven't really asked me
any questions with respect and you're
you're always there okay
does any of that reflect on the prime
minister's integrity
uh monday last when we had the vote of
confidence 59 of mps back the pm uh
we're getting on with their job the
challenge of the cost of living we've
still got an acute issue in relation to
ukraine that can't just slip off the
radar and i'm talking about rape courts
and the crucial job we're doing fighting
crime and giving women uh greater
confidence in the justice system okay
here's the really simple question to use
not one but two ethics advisors and an
anti-corruption czar your position is
that does not reflect negatively on the
prime minister's integrity i mean that's
nonsense well in relation to law guide
it's not clear to me at all uh that
what the reason is and so i mean i think
you've been asking me about that there
are clearly these issues um around the
other commercially uh sensitive matter
which he was engaged on or asked to
advise on my understanding was that
again to the best of my knowledge
as of earlier this week he was planning
or he was hoping to stay on for another
six months
he's obviously had that grilling in
front of mps so i think
the risk is you're adding one plus one
and getting three but i understand we're
asking the question there'll be a
further update from number 10 later
would you would you if you were in
number 10 right now not to publish the
statement that the letter that he wrote
to the prime minister you may have to
redact if there are if there are issues
of national security or whatever else
you can redact the letter but the fact
that you haven't put in the public
domain the resignation letter of the
second ethics adviser to depart
government looks awful
well look i i i only know what he said i
don't i didn't know and i don't know
whether he's written a letter or not
what i do know is number 10 will provide
an update later on today so you're not
going to have to wait too long i
appreciate all the gaps what i always
like to do when i come on here is tell
you the best the best of my knowledge
what i know and i always appreciate it
let's dwell a little bit closer to your
brief on the issue of rwanda the front
of the daily mail this morning seems to
suggest that you would be willing or the
government is considering at some point
in the future ignoring decisions
judgments handed down by the european
court of human rights it was barely 24
hours ago yeah your colleague tweezer
coffee italy's coffee was sitting there
telling me that this was a law-abiding
government i mean that's nonsense if
this is true
no you're again um a slight caricature
of what is a complex legal position so
first of all we'll be introducing and
publishing our bill of rights shortly
one of the issues that's arisen is
whether strasbourg has a power of
injunction now this issue on whether
these deportation flights should be uh
uh stayed pending a further trial of all
the further hearing of all the issues in
a few weeks time was considered by the
high court mr justice swift read the
judgments very interesting he clearly
said no there's no need for an
injunction was then considered by the
court of appeal they backed him
wholeheartedly supreme court said no
need for there was no leave to appeal to
the supreme court i think
when three courts and i have got great
respect for the judiciary in this
country i've considered and dismissed
the issue it is not right for strasbourg
uh to intervene in the way it did you're
limitless physical we're just we're
we're just the year let me explain why i
said high court court of appeals supreme
court where is the eca so let me so
first of all actually the european
convention if you look at it has no
power of injunction and indeed the
strasbourg court
we have followed judgments of the echre
no no no it's a very 80
i'm not going to get the foreign your
viewers need unless you just allow me to
briefly explain it i'll take any
question you like on this issue the
strasbourg itself has said for many
years that there's no binding power of
injunction and then later on they said
well actually we can issue such binding
judgments it is not grounded in the
convention what i would say to you is we
should abide by the convention but so
should the strasbourg court and on this
specific issue of whether strasbourg can
injunct uh
the uk our bill of rights will correct
that and i think it's the right thing to
do precisely because
we should be following the convention
but also so should the strasbourg court
are you considering stepping back from
the european convention on human rights
changing it yesterday therese coffey
appeared to suggest no lunch time the pm
spokesman appeared to suggest yes well
look if you're asking me forever and a
day i think we need to see the
no no no our plan and i've already
consulted on it so everyone can see
is a bit of rights that reflects and
remains within the european convention
but overhauls the the framework of the
human rights act and make sure that we
can fully avail ourselves of what's
called the margin of appreciation which
is what the strasbourg court says
national jurisdictions are allowed to do
in particular in cases like this okay
let's talk uh just just just briefly one
final point in all of this and the the
prime minister has accused your former
colleagues in the legal profession as a
betting the work of criminal gangs i
just want to show you um one tweet
kailyn gallagher is a qc
she has basically be she's had to be
confront she'd had to have a
conversation with the police because of
threats that have been made to her life
can get it into the world yeah
today i met a police officer but death
threats i've got for being a human
rights lawyer today i read the pyramids
words criticizing laws representing
asylum seekers these things are not
unrelated this government is undermining
the rule of law and putting us all at
risk at the very least will you push
back on this idea that anyone who
represents an asylum seeker about to be
deported to rwanda is some form of lefty
lawyer whatever that is well look so
first of all let me choose my words very
ken he is the justice secretary i think
that i've already been very
complimentary i think about the role of
our judges i don't comment on individual
cases but as i mentioned high court
court of appeal and supreme court on
these issues uh i i believe we should
respect their rulings
between the prime minister's words and
the death and the threats to our life
that she is look at any threat to any
lawyer or anyone else and politicians
get this a lot and i know journalists do
absolutely are unacceptable but the
point that the pm made is this and look
i know the lawyers work heroically
through covid and with the backlog we
need them and they're crucial to getting
the backlogs down could you tell your
colleagues that then i'm running hold on
i i also think i'm sorry i also think
it's fair to say that we've got with the
human rights act elastic interpretations
of human rights an industry that has
grown up which of course wants to take
advantage of those in their interests
their clients and i think it's right to
say we want to reform some of that but
but i also would say we've got a
world-leading legal profession it's one
of the great exports we have around the
world and i'm very proud of them and
there are no threats against them that
can ever be justified they will be they
will be very pleased to hear you say
that let's now go to your announcement
and as i said it is it is a significant
announcement but at the same time we
should also point out for the time being
at least a pilot
well um
yes and actually we ought to pilot
things to see the evidence of course of
course let me make two points first of
all uh the backlogs because of the
pandemic uh the plight of cases
particularly for rape victims i think is
it's gotten worse it was it was bad
beforehand come on let me answer the
question actually in the last year
convictions in rape cases have gone up
by two-thirds i want to go first further
faster and really grip this issue
there's a whole range of things we're
doing what i'm announcing today is three
specialist courtrooms kitted out to deal
with rape and serious sexual violence
we've chosen snaresbrook in london leeds
in newcastle because they've got a high
volume of rape cases and significant
backlogs we're kitting them out with the
video technology the trauma-trained
court staff and the independent sexual
advisors for two reasons first of all
morally we must put our arms around
those most vulnerable uh traumatized
victims it's the right thing to do
second of all that will drive up further
the volume of convictions which i want
to at least double over the course of
this parliament and just on that point
to conclude i do have to let you go but
the reason that this is a significant
announcement is because for a number of
years now this country has been
performing incredibly poorly when it
comes to securing rape convictions
2015-16 we had 4643
1557 and up to 2020 2020 2021 some have
accused this government of failing women
you may well be putting it right but you
have to concede that for a number of
years now this government has been
getting it wrong well
of course the police are independent the
cps are independent judiciary
independent but are the have the numbers
been too low absolutely we should be
absolutely crystal clear we're doing a
whole range of things the police and the
prosecutors under operation satiria
which i look at with kit malt house the
police minister is getting a better
collaborative approach between them
we're overhauling the disclosure rules
we've got more pre-recorded victim
evidence so the victims of rape don't
have to give their evidence in front of
the glare of the courtroom we've got
these specialist courtrooms fitted out
and can i just say again the volume of
convictions in rape cases is up by
two-thirds the
law level very very okay but even from
2019 they're up by close to a third and
the the length of time between charge
and completion of case of cases is down
by 38 days on last last year is there a
major challenge absolutely
have the levels of convictions been too
low absolutely are we making progress
undoubtedly next time we speak we will
dwell on the pilot a little bit more
dominic rad thank you for being able to
talk to you
quick look at the morning's front pages
and we begin with the metro the only way
is ethics i see what they did there
that's how the metro describes the
announcement uh that lord gait quit
at the eye uh also making the
resignation its front page lead
suggesting uh that lord quit in protest
here's the telegraph it says the lord
guide is concerned that the prime
minister breached the ministerial code
over parties at downing street
the guardian says the latest resignation
piles more pressure on a beleaguered
broadest boris johnson
you may well be picking up a theme here
there the times taking a similar line
about growing pressure on the pm
our political correspondent ali
fortescue is back once again good to see
you this morning ali what did you make
of it well i think you know clearly
something has gone wrong in the last 24
hours lord guyt the second
man that directly advises a prime
minister on ethics to go in
two and a half years alex allen before
him went when priti patel was accused of
bullying and remember just last week we
had john penrose who's a sort of
anti-corruption tsar in government
resigning as well so clearly this is not
good i think one of the big questions
today is the kind of details of this why
did he go because we got such a short
statement from lord guyt and we
understand behind the scenes there was a
strongly worded letter statement exactly
it was literally just saying i'm
resigning um and i thought the answer
there from dominic rob on that was was
fascinating he said that he's early in
the week wanted to stay on for another
six months he suggested that perhaps the
grilling by mps he got the day before
remember before committee but a lot of
that was about you know the kind of
the limits of his role as ethical
advisor because ultimately the prime
minister kind of override what he says
and we know that there had been unease
he'd written a letter where he said you
know there were questions about whether
the prime minister a legitimate
questions about whether the prime
minister broke the ministerial code but
he also i'm going to read this out
because it's it's a bit odd he said that
he was asked to look at commercially a
commercially sensitive matter in the
national interest
i
i'm gonna try after this to work out
what exactly that means but um but i
don't think right now we are any clearer
as to why um the prime minister's second
ethics advisor has gone and he's now
searching for a third within two and a
half years or indeed why his resignation
military hasn't been published ali for
now thank you
quick reminder as to our top stories and
as we've just been discussing boris
johnson's adviser
lord gang has resigned he is the
second person in that role to leave the
post during the pm's time in office
police in brazil searching for missing
missing journalist dom phillips and his
colleague bruno pereira said the suspect
has confessed and led them to two bodies
the bank of england is expected to raise
interest rates for a fifth time in a row
in a bid to bring inflation under
control
now the home secretary has vowed to
press ahead with plans to send some
asylum seekers to rwanda after a
last-minute court ruling halted the
first flight i'm joined now by the chief
executive of the refugee council enver
solomon enver good to see you this
morning um
let us let us start with the the the
delays and we must call them delays for
the time being at least uh to those
flights uh leaving for rwanda what was
your reaction uh when you heard that
that flight had been
halted well not surprisingly i was very
pleased that we had this last minute
injunction and the flight was stopped
i think there's no need for us to be
sending people uh and treating them
really so they're human cargo shipping
them thousands of miles across the world
to east africa when we should be giving
them a fair hearing on uk soil there's
many people
that come to this country and indeed
people that are watching this program
will have relatives extended family
members
some that might have fled nazi germany
others that have fled places like the
former yugoslavia
wars that have taken place over the last
decades who have come to the uk
taking dangerous routes because they've
had no choice and we've always given
them a fair hearing on uk soil we
absolutely must continue to do that
today
so whenever as indeed happened with me
this week speaking to the working
pension secretary's coffee the
government maintains that there are safe
routes to the united kingdom there are
safe routes to seek asylum here
you would disagree with that
absolutely and that's a really important
point because the reality is that if
you're in afghanistan today and you're
fleeing for your life from the taliban
there isn't really a safe route because
we're only taking a few thousand more
from afghanistan this year and it's a
very limited category of people
you can't just walk into the british
embassy in afghanistan and say i need a
visa to get to the uk because my life's
in danger so you have no other choice
but to take a dangerous journey and not
surprisingly
if you look at those that have come
across the channel and they're like in
the first three months of this year
the main nationality was afghans and
that tells us that there aren't the safe
routes for people to get here there's
one thing that pretty patel could do at
a stroke of a pen which is she could
allow all afghans that are in the uk to
bring any family member here who's in
fear for their life but she's refusing
to do that she's refusing to provide the
kind of safe routes for afghans that are
needed
all of which means the government is
said on something of a collision course
with organizations like yours and
lawyers representing uh those who are
due to be deported
in the courts once again and and of
course the biggest of those will be the
the one testing the legality it's
difficult to predict how these things
will go
but pretty clearly we could be locked in
protracted legal battles for some time
before a plane takes off
indeed it looks like that and i think
it's interesting that government sources
are briefing out to some of the national
newspapers
this morning saying that it looks as
though it could be many months up to a
year before any plane takes off and i
think this just tells the story of how
this policy
is fundamentally ill-thought-out it's
unworkable it's unprincipled and it's
most importantly it's not going to deal
with the problem that it's trying to
tackle it's not going to act as a
deterrent it's not going to stop people
seeking safety in the uk
we need to rethink and we need to adopt
a more sensible
principal approach we need to have a
fair orderly asylum system and
critically we need to work with our
european neighbours to come up with
solutions to share responsibility
france takes twice more asylum
applications germany
three times more this is a challenge
facing the whole of europe the movement
of people fleeing war and persecution
and it requires a multilateral response
in the same way that in tackling climate
change we get round the table with other
nations we need to do the same today in
relation to people
fleeing war to come to europe and the uk
edward not not for the first time i will
admit to being somewhat confused this
morning as to what exactly the
government is up to specifically on the
european convention on human rights
speaking to teresa yesterday the
strongest indication uh that at least
she disagreed with backing away from the
echr if not that the government was not
looking at it today dominic rabb again
slightly more ambiguous i won't ask you
to comment on what the government's
policy is but whether or not you think
that in the 21st century the united
kingdom should be taking steps away from
that document that you know we know
precisely why it was created and when it
was created
well i think the government's position
is clearly confusing and i think there's
clearly contradictions here because we
have a government that is the first to
condemn
human rights abuses in ukraine and we've
seen the pictures of the terrible
atrocities there we've seen the faces of
people fleeing war and persecution and
that reminds us
of the importance of providing
protection for safety for refugees when
they come to our country regardless of
how they get here
yet at the same time we have a
government that is saying and
questioning the human rights of people
who are refugees and there seems to be a
deep contradiction here and my concern
is that as a country
as soon as we start questioning people's
human rights and their rights
under international treaties to be
treated in a way that respects their
humanity
to treat them with compassion as soon as
we start questioning that i fear we risk
going to a very bleak place and we
damage our reputation as a country
there's a very simple parallel if you or
i was stopped by the police tomorrow if
we were accused of a crime if we were
taken down a police station arrested we
would want our rights respected we would
expect that in the same way that if
someone has fled war and persecution
comes to the uk they haven't committed a
crime they simply want to be given a
fair hearing and it's absolutely right
that we treat them with fairness
humanity dignity and compassion
enver good to have you on the program
this morning enver solomon there uh from
the refugee council
now let's turn our attention to
archaeology and archaeologists working
on the hs2 project say they've uncovered
more than 140 anglo-saxon burials at a
construction site in buckinghamshire the
fines include jewelry swords shields and
spears as skye's dan whitehead reports
so this particular individual was found
with a sharp iron object embedded into
the lumbar spine
it was a gruesome end to this young
man's life
now one and a half thousand years later
his remains are among hundreds of items
discovered at a major anglo-saxon burial
site unfortunately we can't let our
imaginations run our wild we have to try
and keep as open mind as possible what
we can tell is that this blade was left
in the individual when they died so it's
very possible that it was a cause of
death also we have the blade mark within
this is the second lumbar vertebrae
which is the bottom of the spine
the skeleton was discovered under a
stretch of the hs2 railway construction
site in wendover
other finds include brooches buckles
glass and spears
there have been hundreds of thousands of
artifacts uncovered so far the eventual
ambition is that they will find their
way into local museums along the hs2
route while hs2 causes some controversy
above ground below it is proving a
treasure trove of britain's history so
hs2 is a fantastic archaeological
opportunity to excavate
areas of the country that wouldn't
necessarily otherwise be developed it's
a series of digs
put together along the route and it's
across a variety of different landscapes
as well so we're
we're starting to get a good picture of
those landscapes all the way from you
know deepest prehistory through the
roman period um through to the saxon
period and through into the medieval
period as well
this is one of the largest anglo-saxon
burial sites ever found in britain a
discovery that experts say is of
national significance
dan whitehead sky news
now let me tell you about a frankly
extraordinary
rescue uh you can just about make him
out there that is ten-year-old rahul
he was trapped in a well in a village
in central india for four days poor
little lads he has now thankfully been
found alive he is both deaf and mute and
fell into the hole
on friday rescuers say they found him
with only a snake for company he's now
recovering in hospital after more than
500 people spent several hours bringing
him to safety well done to them too
meanwhile a hall of fake and potentially
dangerous wonka chocolate bars worth 22
000 pounds have been seized from a shop
on london's oxford street there they are
there at westminster city council said
the chocolate was among counterfeit
products worth a total of a hundred
grand taken away by officers who raided
three unnamed stores all part of an
investigation into 30 american-style
suite and souvenir shops for alleged
business rates evasion amounting to get
this 7.9 million
now as ukraine pleads for more weapons
to help it fight off russian advances
i'm going to be joined after the break
by the former commander of the joint
forces command general richard bans
[Music]
welcome back ukraine has said it
urgently needs more weapons to help it
fight russian advances
the appeal aimed at the west comes as
the leaders of germany france and italy
are visiting these the latest pictures
of the leaders arriving in the ukrainian
capital and of course at the same time a
meeting of nato defense ministers at
taking place in brussels
we're joined now on the program by the
former commander of the joint forces
command general richard bans general
barnes very good morning to you um an
awful lot for us to discuss and as a and
as always not enough time so i wonder if
we can start with what is going on
currently on the ground
in ukraine uh
once again we see
the russians apparently using such
indiscriminate tactics in and around
severed and yet around 80 of the area is
now controlled by moscow what is your
assessment of where exactly we are in
terms of this conflict and who indeed is
in the ascendancy right now
so in that battle in the donbass the the
russian side holds the initiative it
it's grinding its way forward through
the brutal application of firepower and
the lives of young soldiers and the
ukrainian military have provided really
stiff resistance but they they don't yet
have the capacity to stop that russian
advance so this advance will end either
when russia decides it's gone far enough
or uh one way or another it's run out of
steam and that point is not yet
uh it is very likely that the whole of
the luhansk
area will um fall to russia first and
then we'll see and then the war won't be
over because they're still fighting in
the south around curson which is just as
important because on the on that battle
may hang the future of really vital
places like odessa
so on the basis of that and indeed on
the basis of what we've been seeing in
and around the country we understand
that vladimir zelinsky is again asking
the west as he as he has done constantly
consistently of course for more
assistance more arms more material what
is he looking for what can we possibly
provide that that at least might
ameliorate the damage that is happening
in the east of the country if not
actually turn the tide
so i think president zalensky's ask is
going to have two parts the first part
is he needs
now quickly
enough long-range precision artillery to
counter the russian advantage in
firepower because that's the way that
they can make the russian advance stop
on their own terms they're getting some
of this uh assistance it's not there yet
it's not there yet in enough quantity
and of course it needs the ammunition
and training to go with it but but
that's how ukraine makes the russian
invasion stop and the second part of the
ask is then he's going to need more
stuff for longer uh to rebuild his
military in order to be able to build
the offensive capability to throw russia
out of ukraine
uh estimates vary but we perhaps could
see as many as twelve thousand people
still within uh the city of um
understandably then another humanitarian
corridor is being attempted i wonder
what are the chances that on this
occasion that humanitarian corridor will
work effectively unlike the the number
of stop starts that we saw
around mario paul
it's very unlikely to work until unless
russia sees advantage in doing that and
so where russia to decide it has gone as
far as it wants to or can in the donbass
it might try and make a virtue of
letting people out of cities like this
so that they no longer
are a threat to them and they no longer
have to look after them so that would be
quite i think quite a callous
way in which these humanitarian
corridors might be but where we are
right now they're just part of the
battle
um can we talk then general just briefly
about about this nato meeting that is
taking place today um
and what might come of it clearly
as we talk about accession of a couple
of countries into the nato organization
clearly nato was restructuring
readjusting itself when that process is
finished when the pieces in the
kaleidoscope have settled what do you
expect nato to look like how will this
strategic reprioritization take place
i think we're going to see two very
major changes in nato in in the short to
medium term nato is revitalizing itself
remobilizing the alliance because it's
seen what russia is really like under
president putin and what it's capable of
doing so it's going to reset the
conventional defense and deterrence of
of europe with the new members as they
as they line up and then just over the
horizon and nato will talk about this at
its summit in in madrid later this month
nato will work out what part it wants to
play in
in this conversation we're going to have
in our world about how the world with an
ascendant china really works
how concerned should we be and i i'm as
brutal as you as you like your general
uh this is not my area of expertise but
how concerned would should we be when
kremlin spokesman are talking about
relations with the united states being
at a very hot point the confrontation is
approaching a likelihood
so i think we we want to be cautious but
also realistic and russia is going to
continue to talk up the prospects the
dangers of escalation in order to try
and get the west led by the u.s to dial
down the support that it's giving to
ukraine and the way that nato now
re-mobilizes but we should recognize it
in our on our own interests we we need
ukraine to win
and we have an obligation
and uh own pure self-interest to support
them to do that and then we need to be
able to protect ourselves so we're going
to have to live with this very difficult
relationship for at least i think a
generation
how how secure then do you think
vladimir putin's position is within the
kremlin
i think president putin's position in
russia is is secure because we need to
remember this this isn't a war just
between president putin and ukraine this
is a war where a very large number of
the russian population perhaps 80
million genuinely supported and it's a
combination of the information that they
receive and also their view of russian
history and russia's place in the world
that this is not just a a war with a
small clique in the kremlin
um and general just a final thought from
you if we can kind of go if we can kind
of go macro just for a second what has
been urine your assessment of the
ukrainians the way in which that they
have uh prosecuted this this war their
response in fact i should say to an
invasion
how impressed have you been by them and
where perhaps have you found them
lacking
so i think everyone has to be impressed
by by the iron will and the the spirit
of national resistance we've seen from
um ukraine we should recognize they knew
this day would come they knew that the
russians would invade again after 2014
and and we should also recognize that
that we the west we simply failed to
give them
the military means they needed to deter
and defeat that invasion and now we're
all playing catch up but but we we may
have made an emergency out of this but
our obligation to help ukraine secure
its future is no less
uh general richard panz thank you so
much for your time this morning
appreciate it thank you
time for a quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the hot weather will continue in the
south into the weekend with temperatures
peaking on friday at around 34 degrees
celsius 33 in old money the atlantic
rain belts that have been plaguing the
northwest through the week will spread
southward on saturday introducing colder
air and temperatures well rather more
commensurate with the time of year it is
a beautiful start to the day for much of
the country the northwest the exception
i'm afraid uh some more clouds and a few
showers it will become very warm in the
strong sunshine across england wales the
east midlands temperature and the
southeast likely to see the highest
temperatures
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
just got time to show you some of the
great snaps from around the world
capturing the first of this year's four
summer super moons the so-called
strawberry moon the name given to the
last moon of spring before the summer
solstice was photographed in the
backdrop of some iconic landmarks uh
this here
well that's dresden in the east of
germany let's just show you one more
shall we
and here it is in istanbul more from
that a little bit later stay right where
you are after the break are we getting
labor's nick thomas simmons response to
that which we heard from dominic wrap
[Music]